when you were in prison you were a boxer
weren't you well my uncle started me
boxing when I was about 8 years old he
was fighting Golden Gloves and and I was
I was his uh punching B I was trying
sparing
partner punch so I either had to learn
how to fight or get my brains beat so I
I I got really really good so when I
would get into prison immediately they
would set me up with a fight oh let's
and prison you were uh lightweight and
Welterweight Champion unbelievable and
you said professional boxers would come
to the prison
you ever sit in prison and go I'm a
Champion if my life had gone a
little differently you probably could
have been a heavyweight champion of the
world or how let me tell you something
my life ambition was to be welterweight
champion of San Quinn right so you know
it's like I think one of the things that
prison taught me now you know is like uh
I would rather shoot for the moon and
Miss than aim for The Gutter and make it